Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to 'Hello Neighbor'!
Now, we've made a bit of an error here.
I, uh, I exited out of the game
and I didn't realize, that it wasn't going to save MY progress.
So everything, that I've done up until this point
is for naught.
And I have NOT, made any progress.
But, that's okay...
because, generally speaking
I KNOW where to go from here!
BUT, uh...
At the same time, I don't think, uh, the neighbo-WOW.
I am just stuck still. Aren't I?
The neighbor is going to be wandering around again,
and I, know it was a little bit cheat-y for him to be stuck in a wall
or a window, while I was prancing around  his house.
But that's OK. Because I know where everything is now
and I also- woaAAAHH
I don't what the FUUck HAPPend.
OKAY? PHYSICS GOT wEIRd for a second there.
Also I can't see shit. But I think...YES!
Okay, I got the magnet! So that's GOOOOD.
And then I can utilize this, to be able to dooooooo what I need to doooooo.
But the only problem...*Neighbor gasps* Why, again already?
That's a little early, don'tcha think? But I'm gonna do this before you got me.
*glass breaks* HEY HEY! OH FUCK-hi-
Ughhh
Fuck, I forgot how scary he was...
I went so long without him getting me that I totally forgot that he's actually a threat.
So, what I gotta do is I gotta get in his house now.
I gotta sneak, I gotta sneak everywhere.
So, I also need a flashlight and I'm pretty sure there's one up here...
I'll be back once I get everything that I need and I explore this guy's weird ass house...
I just wish there was a clue to know when he was a-comin'.
Lights really are limited in the distance but at least the power's on here!
I-I think that's a good thing anyway...
Hey!
FUCKING! I don't know where you AREEEEE?!
I haven't opened all the side doors yet, you sack of shhiiaaat
STOOP!
STOP IT!
STOP!
Eugghhh, slender noises!
YOU'RE A BAG OF DICKS!
Ah, fuck you.
God, there's-THERE'S NO STIPPY-STEPS FOR THAT BOY! Fhuhuhuhuhuuuck
Alright, you know what? I'm gonna bash open one of the windows  Whoopsie's
I'm gonna bash open one of the Whoopsie's
I'm gonna bash open one of the... one of the windows in the back and that way I'll be able to s-slip
*Neighbor gasps*
Fucking, again!?
HE SAW ME THROUGH A GODDAMN WINDOW!
Probably- Ohhh...
Probably because I got my flashlight on so I'm just gonna be stealthy about it...
Not that one.
One back here that I can baash.
Okay.
So, let's just break some property...
Hup!
Yay! :D
He'll not notice that in a million yars .
Oh!
Well, that's handy! You just hop over it!
That makes my life way easier...
Okay.
Haboodoobooski!
*Neighbor gasps*
Woah...
Haboodoobooski!
Okay, I'm not gonna open that yet because I don't- Oh...
Hey!
Aw, shucks! Darn it!
Okay, yeah, forget about me.
Okay, I'm gonna make this one the first try, buddyboo.
I'm gonna make this on the first try... (ok then)
AHHHHHHHHH!
Fuck...
So, we've got a bit of problem but that's okay.
Oh!
Oh, it IS a face!
Oh, that- that's horrifying.
WUUUGHHHH!
Fuck...
Too early.
Too early on the hippty-hop...
This is going to take me a LOONG time.
WAHP!
Paboo-WOAHH! HEY! YEAH-HA!
YEAH!
GET THIS THE FUCK OUTTA HERE! *miss*
FU-Oh...
I was about to say fuck your face but I don't think that's kosher.
Shoop!
Got that.
Put that there.
Pick that up.
Got that.
Okay. EUhHhH
Yaassss!
YASSS!
Open this up...
Niiiice!
*Neighbor gasps*
Oh.
FUUUCCK!
AH!
Fucking nice mustache
Fucking asshole! At least he doesn't take my shit anymore...
How? Really? Really?! Oh, and he fixed his dang window!
What a bunch of poopy!
Sneaky, sneaky...
Oh, fuck, I just threw the key...
God dammit, I just threw the key.
WHY DID I THROW THE KEY?
Oh no.
Oh no! Where did I throw the key?
WHHHAT THE FU-Oh good, it's over there
Okay, here's the Earth...
ROUND!
Doopy-boop, and open- Oh, hi...
And close.
I forgot you were standing there, you big dingus.
Okay.
So, I'm going to assume that I don't need this key anymore; I'm gonna drop this key off
and that's going to be the last of it!
So, I'm roughly where I was before but the only problem is that I need to get back over here so...
EUAHHHHhHhHh
Frick, I missed...
How about you, do you want to go for a ride?
eUhGhHghghgGHHG (what the hell, Mark)
Wow.
HaaaAAAahhhh *glass breaks*
Got that one! EUGHHH! *glass breaks*
There we go, got IT!
Okay, everything's happy and fun. Imma move you.
So you're in- *Neighbor gasps* WHOA
What the fu- I forgot. Uhhh AHHHHHH! *Neighbor attacks*
Oh... fuck I FORGOT that he's ACTUALLY a threat, again.
It was so NICE when he didn't BOTHER me
Like an A-hole.
Also I NEED this up there. I need to be able to see.
I am- WHY am I still holding this lamp?
* Neighbor gasps*
Oh fuck, it's so problematic when *singing* he's going around!
*still singing* and do all his *stops singing* bullshit
How can he know?
HOW CAN SHE SLAP? HOW CAN HE SLAP MY ASS?!
Okay, now that he's stopped being a douche-nozzle!
Maybe I should be able to sneak into your goddamn HOUSE!
I don't even like your house that much!
It's a big, bag of ASSES!
AND so are YOU!
And I hate you and you smell bad!
*whispers* And you don't even have any... *leans into mic* FaMily or FriEnDS.
HEH. Got him.
*Neighbor gasps*
FUCKING AGAIN?!
Okay you know what? I'm- I'm going for it. I'm going for it.
I'm launching..You know what, actually I'm going down here.
Go..GO! Just FALL in the...FUCKING hole.
You ASS!
Okay, you know what, I needed to go down here
because I need to get this. (the keycard)
Can you open? Thank you.
Can you grab that? Thank you.
FUCK. Why's everything got to be such dick-atry?
ALL the time. EVERY MOMENT OF MY DAY IS FILLED WITH DICKS
AT ALL TIMES!
WHY?
Oh.. ~OHHHHH, I SEE, what I gotta do. Oh, I know~
~OH I KNOW ABOUT THAT. Oh, I don't know how I'm gonna get there though~
~Maybe from the outside? I can get in there, but I don't think so~
Oh fuck, I don't want to go back down.
BUT I GOTTA GO BACK DOWN BECAUSE I GOT NO OTHER WAY TO GO.
Here we go... EUGHHH!
Oh fuck, close.
Ah, I'm on a time crunch, now. *Mark noises*
*Chair falls over* Fucking, get out of the way, you goddamn chair!
*Mark screams* HAH! Yes.
Okay. WHA! They're open..  They're not broken again.
Fuck.
Uh.. Shit. I don't have anything on me that I can throw.
I guess I could throw this?
AH! I'LL COME BACK FOR YOU!
YOU DIDN'T IT EVEN BREAK IT, YOU ASS!
MAN, it is really inconvenient with him actually being there.
Let's try this again.
I'll get the magnet, just in case I neeeed it. You never know!
Three..two..LAUNCH!
YES! Okay, and then I'm- I'ma- I'm just going to go out this one
'Cuz I don't think there's anything else, ANNNNYWHERE ELSE! That I need.
Whoa...OH. No no no no. No, how can you get up here?
You can't! That's the answer.
hhhhhhEEEEEAAAAAAboosky
hhhHHEAAAAAboosky
hhaaABOOSKY haAaHBOOSK
hhhaaAAAAAABOOSKaY!
Oooh, fuck you..
Haboosky
HaBoOsky
K. So how the fuck do I get over this one?
Because, I knOw I gotta get over that one.
There's like, there's two platforms that I can go down
but I gotta be able to get there first.
The unfortunate thing is there is nothing really...
I guess I could catch my fall if I just go
strAight into it.
haAH- Nooope, that did not work.
Well this is- this is problematic.
Why would this be here if you couldn't do this?
Unless there is a key or something that I can magnetise from this junkchure!
Get a running start- eUGHHHHH
oOOooOOOO
cLOSEeE YEAHHSSSS
OKAY!
WE MADE IT HERE!
Oh, what does this mean?
Oh, I'm up here, I'm on his house.
Ok, so there's a drop-in over there.
That looks scary.
Ooh, thAat's scary place!
I need like uh... I need like a platform.
Maybe if I go down heeur? Yeah.
OOooyoyoyoy
Oh whoayoyoah. Okay.
Be careful.
Be careful!
Oh wait, I could've broken this at any time!
I could've broke in through this damn window
Why didn't I?
I didn't even think about that.
Ah EUugh
Whoad no nOoooo
Hey, whoa, I need you.
I need you for stuff.
No! Stop throwing it! Jeez!
Is there anything i can get?
Ff- STOP THROWING IT!
Hey! Fucking why?
Oh god (4x)
Do NOT come out here!
*Whoa noises*
Did he just install that?
He just insta- AAH fucking god dammit you fu- OH FUCK YOU!
F-FUCK YOU!!
You know what? FUCK you!
That is such dick! I could've got in that room! I didn't even fuuuuck!
I didn't even fuck.
Fucken sto- STOP!!!!
What a dick hole, he's putting bear traps everywhere because he's an ASSSS
Fucking, i just wanna go to the DOOOOOOOR!
Fuc- UUUURRRGG UHUH!
Can you..For once...just not..
*Neighbor gasps* Why???
Every time. Are you just there every time now?
Is that- Is that your prerogative? Just to be there EVERY TIME?
*Neighbor gasps* OH MY GOD, YOU ARE!
That IS it! ...you fucking asshole...
Or- you know what, I'll come back for that, because I don't even have the means with which to rip off the door.
*Neighbor gasps* Gah.. Wha?
*Mark screams* STOPPP!
FuckING UGHHHH
Again, never leaves that place.
Never leaves. Never leaves.
*Neighbor gasps* OHHHHH COME ONNN
fUCKING GODDAMNIT
fuck THIS..  ASSSSSHOLEEE!!
Is he right here? Is he right here?
No for once he's not. Okay.
Okay. So that's like that but I still
OH. Peer through the keyhole here.
Whoa.
Whoa. Oh, no. That's just a bug.
Okay, can't see in there, there's nothing to see.
SO, I now unlocked it with a key card.
But what I didn't do, is unlock it with the CroWBAR.
Which I don't even know where it is. It was under a bed last time
But I highly doubt it's going to be there again.
He put soo many cameras up there.
What a dick.
What did just... *throws flashlight*
I fucking threw my fucking flashlight...
Did I REALLY throw my FUCKING flashlight?
The answer is...Yes I did.
Like an asshole, and I'll never be able to find it again.
Unless I use this lamp to find it!
Scoutin' about a location for a fucking flashlight that I accidentally  *Neighbor gasps*
WHYYYYYYY???
Good god, this guy is such a PROBLEM
WHA??
uh.... oh wha...THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSEEEEEE!
I'm in the shadows!
HOW DO YOU KNOW?
THAT DOES'T MAKE ANY SENSE!
I just gotta get back in.
FU- AGain HOW?!
That doesn't MAKE Any SeeeeenSEEE
Oh fuck off..
How and why?
It's like his vision is like- if you're anywhere, even in the vicinity of where he is
You're fucked.
I think I got to turn off power to his house, because...
it's just getting too much of a problem to have him be able to like-
I think the cameras -number one- are bad.
*shuts power off* Okay, so that should... *Neighbor approaches*
WELP, eat a bag of dicks.
Eat a bag of dicks. Eat a baaaag of big ol' dicks.
*gets caught*
ughhhHHHHHHHH
I just wanna get back up to where I was. That's all I want...
WHAAAAA?
WHAT DID I DO?!
I DON'T GET IT!
Ohhh..FUCK you.
Fuck- Mmm-  I don't get it he's sooo like...
it- it- it's IMPOSSIBLE now!
WHYYYY?!
Why is it suddenly impossible?
I mean fuck, man!
It's like I'm in PITCH darkness and he still sees me.
It was not this bad. I mean, I guess he got stuck so
could've been that bad.
BUT HOW?
I mean, I guess, he could've heard the fucking window breaking.
But... other than that
MAN, he is overBEARing!
*Trap snaps* Fu-OHHH
Oh no. OH NO, OH NO. UGH.
ughh
*Neighbor gasps* WHYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYY??
WHY?! I DON'T HAVE A FLASHLIGHT! FUCK YOOOOU!!!
GODDAMmit. It's ABSURDDDD.
Like, something is OBVIOUSLY wrong here.
I can't even get in his fucking house anymore.
Oh my god. I can't see anything anymore.
'Cuz there's no lamp in here.
Give me you. Where's the hole in the ground?
Fucking... I have no idea where I am.
I can't see a goddamn thing,
'Cuz I took the LAMP out of HERE
Fall in the fucking hole!
Just drop me in the fucking HOLE!
I'M RIGHT ON IT!
AREN'T I?
Oh..OH OH. I was- I WAS on it.
I was on the hole.
THERE- FUCK.
Oh my god. I DON'T HAVE A FUCKING FLASHLIGHT!
So NOW, I have a box!
I have ONE box.
That took me fucking forever, I meant to get another box.
Why is dark in- Oh...cause I turned all the power off.
That's right..
I gotta turn that back on because it- it literally did nothing for me.
HOOUP!
Ugh, come on.
WHAT THE FUCKING FUCK
I CAN'T SEE. I DON'T HAVE A FUCKING FLASHLIGHT.
GOD FUCKING DAMMIT.
I lost my BOX.
OH, this is infuriating.
This is FuCKing infuriating.
I'm gonna go down here
Get the fuck outta my way, bucket.
Get the FUCK OUT.
*Neighbor gasps*
It's a fucking bucket- WHY
NOOOOOOOOOOOO FUCK YOU
FUCK YOU! (x2)
FUCK! Get UP THERE!
FUCKING GET UP THERE!
I hate.. I hate this.
Hope that's the right spot.
There we go. Ok.
Alright. We're pretty high up, don't freak out on me.
Oh my gawwwddd.
You are NOT gonna tell me that I need to go fucking over somewhere else!
I need to go over the goddamn lip of the goddamn thing again.
You know what?
I'm just gonna do it THIS way.
No, I'm not 'cause that didn't work.
*breaks window* There we go.
Imma get in this way. Hup!
NooOOOOOOO!!! Fffffucking-
What the FUCK!!!
*Mark noises*
I KNOW what to do, I KNOW what to do...
But... My. GOD!
EUGHH! Okay, there we go. I'm up-
UGH! I FUCKING forgot!
You better fucking nail this on the DOT!
*nails it*
Thank you.
*Neighbor gasps*
Fucking don't.
Don't even bother. You can't-
You can't FUCKING get me, BRO!
Get fucking WRECKED, dick hole!
DICK HOLEEEE!!
Okay, now, here's the million dollar question:
Can I make this jump?
Not if he keeps splashing me with... goop juice.
*goop juice shot*
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!!!!!!!!!
HE FUCKING THREW A GODDAMN GLUE!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
He fucking THREW a glue while I was mid FUCKING AIRRRRRRRRRRRR!!!
I just wanna make progress in this, guys.
I just wanna make progress.
I haven't made a single step of progress since I started this episode.
I have not made a single step towards my goal.
Because HE is the most sensitive piece of shit I've ever seen in my life.
It's like he thinks my flashlight is on permanently.
*sigh of relief*
Well. I got in here.
Didn't think that was gonna happen.
Threw my flashlight away but now I'm here.
So that's- That's a thing.
Can I shoot him?
Can I shoot him in his FUCKING face.
Can I FUCKING shoot him.
I don't have a flashlight so... I don't even know if there's a door here.
Sooo if I'm not mistaken I got in an area where I was supposed to have a golden key...
and now I have a GUN...
Can I shoot him?
*bars spin around*
What the fuck?
Whhhhhhhhat?
Oooookay? That doesn't make any goddamn sense.
Oooohhhhhhhhhh...
Well, now this is open at least. So I got this. And now I have a gun.
I'm gonna shoot this FUCKING asshole.
Come after me!
I FUCKING dare you.
You wanna see if I'm messing with you, bitch?! You wanna see?!
COME AFTER ME.
I FUCKING DARE YOU.
Oh, THERE'S my old flashlight.
You know what?
I'll have TWO. Cause...t-that's how I roll.
Oh, you coming after me? Oh.
MEET ME AT MY HOUSE!!!
Step over the line!!
Step over this line!!
Step over the line!! Huh?!
No?
Fuck- *Neighbor is hurt but not dead*
That...? 'Sup with the...
Is that all that fucking did?
Just a fucking piddly little-
The fuck is this shit?!
This is unlimited, isn't it?
Yeah! HOW THE FUCK DO YOU LIKE IT, HUH?!?!
FUCK YOU!!! Yeah, that's right!
Fuck you!
I' m gonna shoot out every FUCKING window in your FUCKING house!
Huh? What? You saw something?
NO, you DIDN'T. Because FUCK YOU.
What? You thought you could get me? Oh, FUCK YOU.
"EEEGGHHH"
"EEEEGGHHH!"
"EUGH-HEH!" I'm a BITCH!!
Good thing is I should be able to keep him at bay with this.
I mean this is literally- this is literally a neighbor repellent.
This is what this is.
Fuck off, fuck off, fuck off.
And then- wha- fuckingggg noooo!
Oh my god, that was close.
Fuck, I don't know where you areeeee!
I can't see shiitt!
Ugh- I was just shooting wildly, fuck.
*Neighbor gasps* No! I fucking threw my godDAMN FLASHLIGHT!!!!!!!!!!
GODDDDDDDDDAMMITTTT!!!!!
FUCKKKKKKKKKK!!!!!
Ughhh I'm having the worst time...
I've been playing this for almost an hour now.
Trying to make just the SMIDGE more PROGRESS
but it DOESN'T. FUCKING. WORK!
Ohh... All I need are two trashcans and I'm gonna try desperately to get into that FUCKING loft.
But I FUCKING threw my flashlight...
I CAN'T BELIEVE I FUCKING THREW... my fucking flashlight...
Oh, good. I got a spare.
I've got TWO garbage cans. That's probably my best bet for getting in there.
I don't know why. Don't ask me why. I don't know.
As long as I don't throw the wrong thing...
Okay, I'm gonna just put these real close...
*clanking noise*
...
*trashcan is gone*
...where the fuck did it go?
Of course. Ohhh, of course.
It fucking disappeared.
Okay, you know what?
Fuck that.
Maybe it has to do with this.
*slips*
NoooooOOOOOOOOOO- HOOOOookayyy
It's fine..
Maybe I've been an idiot this whole time and it's the goddamn railroad tracks that are literally right next to me.
Maybe that's it because I wou- it would be that because I'm dumb...
and of course it's that.
Huuupp!
Yup! It would be this, wouldn't it? No?
Maybe it WOUDLN'T be this.
Boy, that's really fucking close now, isn't it?
Okay, so it's NOT this.
...that's for damn sure...
I guess I can't-
WOAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
I WAS NOT S'POSSED TO COME IN'ERE!
WHY WAs there a fucking...
...why was there a way to get in?
Why- oh, why??
Why have you done this to me?
There's no fucking reward here!
What was the fucking POINT THEN?!
WUGHHH NUGHHH
I've been trying... for over an hour to get up here.
And there's nnno reason to- there's no reason to get up here
And I BET, I BET, the ONLY way... to get OUT of here...
...is to restack ALL OF THESE BOXES!
ALL these boxes over here... so that you can get out.
THAT'S the only way to get out, isn't it?
Why would you do that?!
Why would y- oh, fuck it, you know what?
Why do I even wanna get back up there?
It doesn't fucking matter.
You know what? I'm all out of time for this because I'm just TIRED!
I'm TIRED of it! I haven't done ANYTHING!
And I discovered that the secrets that I wanted don't EXIST
So I'm gonna leave it at that so...
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
If you got some tips and tricks to actually get past this, lemme know down in the comments below.
...And as always I will see you... in the next video!
BAH BYE!
*Music*